feminism in and of itself can't be  defended any idea the point of an idea  is that can be defended by the people  who believe in it this is what the whole  point of War sits to dawn of time it  doesn't matter if it's the Christians  against the Hindus doesn't matter if it  was the Germans against the French there  were people who had ideas and ideologies  and they're prepared to fight each other  to defend their ideology feminism is an  ideology which cannot be defended by  feminists the only people who could  defend feminism are The Men Who  subscribe to the garbage with you it's  all the feminists were to get in a line  and say we want feminism and the  conservative men were to get in a line  you learn very quickly it's [ __ ]